Максим Гошовський переїхав до України з
Росії понад 10 років тому.
Гошовський був волонтером на Майдані, а потім в зоні АТО.
Чоловік двічі отримував тимчасове
посвідчення громадянина України.  Щоб
отримати повноцінне громадянство, Максим
мав відмовитися від російського паспорта.
Тобто мені треба було поїхати в Росію, сісти там у в'язницю, оскільки я був
активним учасником Революції гідності
волонтером у зоні АТО, вивозив тіла наших
загиблих з Іловайська.
Тобто в Росії на мене точно заведені якісь кримінальні
справи через мою життєву позицію і через те,
що я підтримую Україну.
Наприкінці 2021 року дія тимчасового посвідчення Гошовського закінчилася. Він виїхав з України в Єгипет і знову заїхав по
туристичній візі з наміром отримати
постійну посвідку на проживання в Україні.
За законом у нього було 90 днів на те, щоб подати документи до
міграційної служби - серед іншого довідку
про несудимість.
Запит на цю довідку Гошовський зробив через Російське
консульство. Там йому сказали, що довідка
буде готова 26 лютого, а 24-го Росія
вторглась в Україну.
Два місяці тому Максима зупинили на блокпосту. Звідти
відправили на перевірку у відділ ДМС.
Там волонтеру поставили штамп про примусове
видворення з країни.
Він подав позов до суду.
Намагатимуся потім у суді пояснити і довести, мовляв, а як можна було тут не перебувати дев'яносто днів,
коли ви не приймаєте документи? Я не можу легалізуватися в Україні. Я не можу нічого зробити…
Ситуація Гошовського далеко не поодинока.
За даними ДМС, за цей рік рішення щодо
заборони в'їзду в Україну висунули 421
громадянину Росії, ще 635 про примусове
повернення в країну їхнього походження
або третю країну.
Підходи до опрацювання документів громадян РФ і Білорусі після вторгнення Росії в Україну відрізняються
від інших іноземців: їхні подання або не
розглядають, або ставлять штамп про
примусовий виїзд або просто не приймають.
Що відбулося відбулось? Захисна реакція держави на війну.
Війна - це непередбачувана обставина, ніхто не міг її передбачити і, власне, вибудувати собі якийсь алгоритм дій.
Але, звичайно, було порушено принцип визначеності, тобто ці іноземці, які зараз знаходяться в Україні,
це і громадяни РФ і Білорусі, на жаль, не можуть з початку війни прогнозувати
ані рішення, ані будь-які обставини, які
виникнуть при спілкуванні з міграційною службою.
Юристка Ксенія Проконова спеціалізується на міграційному праві.
Тепер у неї десятки запитів на юридичний
супровід від громадян Росії і Білорусі.
Є люди, які заїхали і просто легально
перебували, ні, не на підставі посвідки, як туристи.
У них закінчується термін їх
перебування, в них немає зараз наразі
жодного варіанту легалізації, вони не
можуть ані податися на нову, наприклад, на
отримання посвідки, ані продовжувати свій
термін перебування.
На думку адвокатки, ДМС мала би розробити окрему процедуру опрацювання документів від громадян РФ.
Тут дуже багато людей, які тут роками
мешкають сім'ями, в яких є бізнес, які
створюють робочі місця, які сплачують
податки, які зробили інвестування в
економіку України, і вони все це робили,
тому що була передбачувана поведінка.
А зараз вона зникла, тобто ситуація змінилась.
Росіянин Максим Пащенко одружений з українкою. До 24 лютого подружжя жило на три країни: Україну,
Росію і Польщу. В Україні Пащенко мав
посвідку на тимчасове перебування.
Термін її дії закінчився, тому незадовго до війни Максим в'їхав в Україну як турист.
Чоловік веде волонтерську діяльність, зокрема разом з російською громадою в Україні збирає кошти для ЗСУ.
Коли 90-денний термін закінчувався, чоловік пішов до міграційної служби поновити свою посвідку, однак отримав відмову.
Я знову зробив подання, хотів отримати нову
посвідку, і мені сказали, що, мовляв, з
росіянами не працюємо. Вони сказали:
просто сидіть, чекайте, але я теж розумію,
що не можу просто сидіти чекати. До мене
можуть прийти. Я знаю, що багатьом людям
виписують розпорядження на виїзд.
На запит DW Державна міграційна служба України відповіла, що чекає на ухвалення закону від Верховної Ради щодо
врегулювання відносин з особами,
пов'язаними з державою-агресором, а поки
цього не сталося...
Однак юристи з міграційного права цих нормативно-правових актів досі не бачили.
За словами адвоката Володимира Жванкова, у цьому і є складність ситуації, адже допоки немає офіційних рішень,
їх не можна оскаржити.
Зараз це неможливо через те, що норми є, але ви можете зіткнутися з тим, що у вас просто не приймуть документи.
Це добре, якщо просто не приймуть, а можуть ще й різними
поганими словами на вас накричати.
І ось не приймають документи, і що, це ж
неофіційна відмова - ви не можете це оскаржити.
В Управлінні верховного
комісара ООН у справах біженців DW
повідомили, що офіційної заборони доступу
громадян Росії до надання притулку в
Україні немає, однак з іншими статусами
легалізації іноземців, зокрема
продовження посвідок, в офісі ООН не
працюють і відповідного моніторингу не ведуть.
Хоча і вказують, що...
На уточнення DW, що означає "працювати не на
повну потужність" в ООН підтвердили, що
йдеться про неприйом документів від
громадян РФ. Водночас правозахисники
кажуть, що це патова ситуація, адже саме
тому, що ДМС не приймає документи росіян,
вони стають нелегалами, і саме це може
нести безпекові ризики для країни.
Логічно саме з метою безпеки поставити
його на облік: він сам своїми ногами
прийшов, йому це потрібно, людина із
задоволенням дасть свій телефон, пройде
всі необхідні співбесіди, дасть доступ до
того, що ви попросите і таке інше. А
нинішні практики змушують людей ховатися,
йти у тінь, і це якраз шкодить безпеці,
коли людина сама іде і готова вам все
показати, тоді ви можете її перевіряти.
Однак поки позиція Державної міграційної служби залишається такою: громадяни РФ належать до громадянства країни-агресора.
Згідно основних засад міжнародного права,
іноземець, який перебуває за кордоном,
користується захистом та заступництвом
держави свого громадянства, не втрачає
юридичного зв'язку зі своєю державою та
підпорядковується нормам законодавства
країни свого громадянства.